[Music]
[Applause]
he's the hall of famer reggie miller on
the program reggie is
doing games from the atlanta studios and
uh had game one with the grizzlies in
the jazz last night
he's gonna have the heaton bucks game
two that's 7 30
eastern and uh then he'll be on the call
for the lakers and
sons that'll be game two tomorrow reg
thanks for joining us uh you're 55
you don't look 55. but
what was the big reason why you couldn't
you stopped playing
there was times when
i got out of bed and it took me a good
12 to 15 minutes just to get to the
bathroom
your knees especially for me my ankles
my ankles
hurt so bad it just took too long to
warm up my body
it's the recovery when you're playing
four games in five nights
you're going against some of the world's
best players especially at shooting
guard
and you couldn't warm up your body it
you know when i was watching phil
yesterday it was riveting um
because it was for us old guys and i'm
sure he doesn't want to hear that
because 50 you're not old 55 you're not
old
you know i'm a semi semi-pro
professional mountain biker and i don't
consider myself old
um but it was one like for us as much
time phil puts into his craft as i put
into my craft
to get that feeling back
i keep telling people winning is like a
drug you know
once you've had a little bit of success
you want it all the time
and phil was in that moment for those
four days
he had that feeling i kind of equate
what he did yesterday and people are
gonna be like what are you doing that's
crazy
when kobe had the 60 points
his last game at 30
it was equivalent to what i saw
yesterday because
you looked in kobe's eyes and he had
that
19 year old kobe bryant look
phil had that 25 year old
look in his eyes on each hole
were there some blunders absolutely
that's golfing
but he had that that walk that
we were accustomed to seeing and i think
the fans and
first of all how great is it to have
fans back at sporting events it was
fabulous to hear all the comments
that were being shouted his way it was
just cool to watch so when
kobe was getting that 60 that like we
knew we were never going to see it again
phil's going to continue to play golfing
events and tournaments and
being majors but i don't know if you'll
ever recapture
that look that walk
um it it was just very cool to see
but do you consider tom brady old do you
consider lebron james
old do you consider i would say
i would say tom brady is old for his
sport
and what he's doing at 43 to be
a top level super bowl
winning contributing quarterback
at at 43 yeah that's old because
look at peyton manning when he won his
last championship
in denver the defense won that
championship
that super bowl payton was more of
a managing quarterback
don't get me wrong it was great but the
defense
and mr miller won that champ that super
bowl
tom brady was making plays he was making
plays to win that super bowl
this time out so yeah he's old for a
suit for a super bowl winning
quarterback
but because of science and technology
and all these recovery tools nowadays
guys can play longer that's just how it
is but why is it that guys in your era
could play 82 games and guys nowadays
can't uh
i'm not saying that they can't well
won't
they won't i think they're looking at
the big picture because i think more
guys want to be
fresher and have more in the tank
come playoff time whereas guys in my era
it was all about just competing go going
out
and and and playing um
i i will say this i was a little
i shouldn't say disappointed i was
shocked and listening to rudy gobert's
comments
post game he was a little shocked that
donovan mitchell wasn't playing
yesterday um because i always felt
me at 75 80 percent is better than a lot
of people at 100
that's how i always approached it so if
i was a little banged up nicked
i had a tweaked ankle i was going to
give it a go
because sometimes you could be a decoy
and
the defense is going to be shifted
towards you this is when you get an
opportunity to get other guys involved
i i would have loved to have seen
donovan mitchell out there
at 75 80 percent now i'm sure he's gonna
come back and play wins
if he doesn't play wednesday then we
know it's much more serious but if he
can play
wednesday he could have played last
night
that's how i look at it give me the uh
team that
has already lost in the first round that
should be nervous
that maybe this isn't an aberration that
maybe
this could be a pattern
i always say this in seven game series
the best team usually rises to the top
cream rises and you'll win the series
but i will say the portland denver
series
portland on paper is a top four team
they just didn't play like it all year
and they had injuries
and damian lillard had to carry this
team while nurkic and mccollum recovered
from injuries early in the season
they kind of found their their their way
down the stretch
that's always been a scary matchup
because lillard is a bucket getter
and camilla playing his old team and you
know we've
heard the booze and some of the comments
coming out of there they have a lot to
prove
and with jamal murray missing from
denver
it's just scary for michael malone and
the nuggets i'm not saying they can't
win that series
jokic has been great probably will win
the mvp
but i kind of like uh portland in that
series
yeah i do too um you know i
i i look at the clippers you know they
they they wanted this matchup
yeah and now i mean if
there's a lot of pressure here on kawhi
leonard remember when kawhi
and lebron and who do you want and kawhi
is a better player and i went you guys
are
full and you have no idea what you're
talking about nobody's talked about
kawhi as one of the great players in the
game it's like oh yeah kawhi
this is his time playoff time this is
what you're supposed to do
and then you lose at home to dallas
all right one game but they don't know
how to stop
uh luca here uh i thought that dallas
would have beaten them in the bubble
last year
you know porzingis got tossed and luca
got hurt you know they they targeted his
ankle there
i thought that they were gonna beat him
last year but any concerns with the
clippers
there's always concerns with the
clippers because you feel that they have
that
clipper curse and you know
he's given him his nickname playoff p
in the first half he was non-existent
and paul george she came alive a little
bit in the second half
look they'll always be pressure on the
clippers because they're
their crosstown rivals are the lakers
and they have all the championships
but you go out and you get kawhi you get
pg
you go out and get sergi baca i mean
this is a team
you and i have talked about this i
thought the lakers and the clippers were
always the two best teams in the west
but right now both of them don't look
like it
and is there a lot of pressure on kauai
absolutely
winning two championships one in toronto
one in san antonio
but i think they are a team that aren't
afraid to go on the road
and win ball games i think they'll win
game two um
but i think they will go into texas and
get another one i think it's a long
series but i still feel that they have a
they have too many players that can
guard
luka doncic when it matters kawhi paul
george
uh patrick beverly so they have
guys that can can play him and kind of
limit him
i'm just worried for dallas if those
guys could continue to shoot like that
because all it takes is one hard hit to
porzingis
and he's going to be out you know
i don't have a lot of faith in porzingis
because he's he's
he's always getting hurt during games
and i don't know
if hardaway can continue to shoot like
that jalen brunson can continue to shoot
like that
to win four games i know luca can i'm
not
i don't my faith is not in the rest of
those guys on that dallas team
we're talking to reggie miller the hall
of famer uh that brings us to the lakers
i'm not surprised they lost the opener
to the phoenix suns
um but it's how they lose i
i don't know anthony davis just was kind
of nondescript
and i don't know he could be you know
more banged up than we know
but the rest of the team that's where
the rest of the team helps
when somebody is not 100 percent what
concerns do you have with the lakers
that lebron and a.d are going to have to
play
near perfect for them to be back-to-back
championships
i think in the bubble where you played
in one or two venues
there was no travel i think you could
get away with that
now that you've got to go into other
people's arenas
i think lebron and a.d especially a.d
a.d is going to show why he's
one of the top 10 players in the nba
he has the talent he has the skill and
with
phoenix being an undersized team he
should be dominating
and we kind of got a glimpse of this
when they played
golden state and escaped let's face it
golden state
should have beaten the lakers in that
7-8 matchup
but golden state they just couldn't you
know
ball security that's not in their dna
they kept turning the ball over and
they're a one-man band with staff
so i'm not surprised i'm more surprised
that a.d
has not taken it upon himself because he
played terrible in golden state
and he played terrible last night with
an undersized
phoenix team he should be dominating and
he's not
and it just goes to show you the thin
margin if they're not healthy which
clearly it looks like they are not
um they're very vulnerable to being sent
home
and i know they're the favorites i know
they're the champs
but right now they are not right
trey young of the hawks hit the game
winner in the garden
and uh had this to say after the hawks
beat the knicks i think it was uh
i mean you know you've you've been in
the bigger stages i mean when you're
i mean in a zone and uh everybody's
chanting fu
i don't know if any of y'all had that
but uh i've had it a couple of times i
had it in college and i had it again at
night so
i mean it got real quiet at the end and
uh for me i
wanted to hear those fu chants again
well you've heard
you've you've heard those comments
before at the garden haven't you reg
there is nothing better mr traeger
than having listening to a rat peon
cotton in there it is so quiet you can
hear it
you can hear it look that's going to be
a great series
because when it shifts to atlanta
see atlanta has never really had a true
home court because everyone travels and
lives in atlanta now
so there will be a very pro knicks crowd
in atlanta and i know spike is going to
travel there he went to morehouse and
uh so you know spike is going to be in
the building
so the knicks can win on the road i
think that goes seven games but
we are seeing some of our young stars in
their first playoff
like come of age trae young we saw john
morant
dylan brooks i mean this is fun to watch
the next generation play at a high level
in the playoffs with all the money on
the table and look fantastic doing it
but if you're trae young do you invite
this now because you always played to
the crowd in the garden you weren't
afraid of that but you were a veteran
you know he's young i mean truly young
at
what 20 years of age but the only
i say yes and the reason why i say yes
is because he has the type of game that
can shut people up
he can knock it down from 35 he's always
going to have the ball in his hands
he's a playmaker i i wanted that
but i didn't have the type of game where
i could control the game
ninety percent of the time because i was
handling the ball i had to receive the
ball from mark and haywood workman and
vern fleming
and guys like that so mr trae young
bring it on his shoulders look broad
it's only going to get worse from here
on out
because i remember the big play the
eight points in nine seconds and
afterwards the knicks choked
john stark's jokes i was saying all this
and i got
we got hammered in game two and i just
remember larry brown just giving me the
riot act
um because of that so it's gonna be a
lot worse
this morning when he's reading the
papers and he's saying all that
the knicks are gonna come after him in
game two so he's gonna have to be ready
but what did spike lee actually say to
you during games
it started with him and the cheryl
chance
and cheryl was better and oh so
that's kind of what started it and then
he got i mean it is true though
like what he was saying was true it was
true
i didn't even hear it from that little
troll over there
so he would just yell out cheryl yeah
he's like put a wig on
girl miller is justin trudeau miller's
out here playing with
i'm like i was like is he really saying
is he really saying this
i was like okay if you're gonna talk
yeah
you're gonna pay all this money for
these expensive seats
you're gonna be a part of the game spike
and i made them part of the game
if you're trey young do you say anything
to spike lee
you have to though spike is up there
dancing
and you know moonwalking on the
sidelines
when the knicks are going on runs you
have to
kobe went through the same thing mj
i love spike that is spike's job he is
the number one
knicks fan and i will go to my grave
saying i admire him because there should
be more people
that are ride or die like spike lee
but it's kind of good to give them a
little bit so trey
next time you knock down a tray look
over there a little bit adam
yeah i would just do a drive-by and just
say
you thought reggie miller was it
was a nemesis that's it yes just because
this
mine was a short window mine started in
93
94 and went to about two thousand you
know that was only a seven eight year
window
trey young could have a 10 to 12 year
window of
tormenting tormenting the knicks
i say go for it reg uh was on the call
grizzlies jazz last night tonight
it's the heat in the box and then
tomorrow night you'll have the lakers
and the suns at 10 eastern all on tnt
we'll talk to you then reg we'll be
watching tonight thanks buddy
i appreciate you theodore and i love you
dance
that's reggie miller the hall of famer
take a break play of the day is up next
here on the dan patrick show